[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin hallo und guten Abend
Christin otto hat später die sportlichen
Nachrichten für uns das Ende eine era
guten Abend und wir starten in die
Sendung mit einer Entscheidung die
weitreichende Konsequenzen haben dürfte
Urteil mit immensen finanziellen und
politischen Folgen der Ampelkoalition
fehl auf einen Schlag 60 Milliarden Euro
für die
Energiewende Kämpfe in Gaza Stadt auch
rund um das größte Krankenhaus dort
suchen tausende Schutz die Armee meldet
sie habe unter der Klinik Waffen der
Hammers
entdeckt und aus für ursfischer nach 14
Spielen ohne Sieg ist der Schweizer
nicht mehr Trainer bei Union
Berlin Deutschlands höchstes Gericht hat
heute entschieden wo Schuldenbremse
drauf steht muss auch Schuldenbremse
drin sein konkret kippt karlsrohr den
Nachtragshaushalt
2021 für die Ampel ist es politisch und
juristisch ein debarkel mit noch
unabsehbaren Folgen immerhin fehlt Ihnen
jetzt diese gigantische Summe 60
Milliarden Euro eigentlich coronageld
dann aber verschoben in den Klima und
transformationsfond bevor wir auf die
Berliner Reaktionen und die Folgen für
die Ampel schauen erklärt uns Samuel
Kirsch die
Entscheidung der Umweltbonus für den
Kauf von E-Autos es sind staatliche
Förderprojekte wie dieses die aus dem
Klima und transformationsfond finanziert
werden finanziert teilweise durch
Schulden 60 Milliarden Euro des Fonds
waren einst Corona notlagenkredite
bewilligt
2021 während der Pandemie die
Schuldenbremse damals ausnahmsweise
ausgesetzt dies notlagenkredite durfte
die ampelregierung nicht nachträglich in
den klimaforumschichten
urteilt heute das
Bundesverfassungsgericht der Zweite
Senat hat wie sie eben gehört haben das
zweite
nachtragshaushaltsgesetz
2021 insbesondere wegen Verstoßes gegen
die Ausnahmeregelung zur sogenannten
Schuldenbremse fürnichtig erklärt denn
ausnahmekredite für Krisen müssen auch
zu Krisenbekämpfung angingesetzt werden
notschulden in die Folgejahre mit ohne
sie auf die Schuldenbremse anzurechnen
das war
verfassungswidrig damit verringern sich
rückwirkend die dem Klima und
transformationsfond zur Verfügung
stehenden Finanzmittel um 60 Milliarden
Euro ein Urteil mit immensen folgen das
klar macht Haushaltsdisziplin ist keine
politische Option sondern
Verfassungsgebot wir wollen das auch
juristisch einordnen mit unserer ZF
Rechtsexpertin SAR ist bei mir im Studio
guten abendar was bedeutet dieses
Grundsatzurteil für politisches Handeln
über den Tag hinaus durch dieses
glasklare Grundsatzurteil ist die
Politik ab sofort und auch für die
Zukunft gezwungen haushaltspolitisch
diszipliniert zu handeln denn die
Richter und Richter haben ganz deutlich
gesagt halt stopp so geht's nicht
Schuldenbremse heißt Schuldenbremse und
von der Schuldenbremse gibt's genau eine
Ausnahme das heißt in Notsituation in
Krisensituation darf ausnahmsweise
zusätzlich der Staat Verschulden aber
eben nur um durch diese Krise zu kommen
was nicht geht ist das was die Ampel
gemacht hat nämlich Geld das in der
Krise ungenutzt blieb beiite zu stellen
und sich dann nach und nach während die
Schuldenbremse schon wieder scharf
gestellt ist daraus bedienen das geht
nicht das ist die klare juristische
Vorgabe aus Karlsruhe und was bedeutet
das jetzt im juristischen Sinne für den
Moment das bedeutet ganz praktisch auch
da gibt's eine klare juristische Vorgabe
aus karlsruh die 60 Milliarden Euro
müssen genauso wieder zurückgegeben
werden das heißt das Geld das schon
ausgegeben wurde muss irgendwie aufgetan
werden und zu zurück in den Topf und das
Geld was eingeplant wurde kann nicht
mehr ausgegeben werden das heißt die
Vorgabe aus Karlsruhe ist auch da ganz
klar offen ist nur wie die Politik nun
das Geld findet Sarah vielen Dank für
deine Einordnung da warten also noch
große Aufgaben und es ist ein Urteil mit
folgen die noch nicht ganz abzusehen
sind die Bundesregierung die verhängte
als erste Reaktionen einen ausgabestopp
für den klimafond durch das gewaltige
Finanzloch entstehen jetzt enorme
Herausforderung vor allem wie die
Energiewende finanziert werden kann über
die Berliner Reaktionen auf das
wegweisende Urteil jetzt Frank
Buchwald sorgenvolle Gesichter heute im
Kabinett die Entscheidung der Karlsruher
Richter für die Ampel ein Schlag ins
Kontor der Kanzler jedoch gibt sich
entschlossen auch wenn ihm 60 Milliarden
jetzt erstmal fehlen das Urteil wird
Auswirkung haben auf den Klima und
transformationsfond deshalb werden wir
den Wirtschaftsplan des Klima und
transformationsfonds im Lichte des
Urteils nun zügig
überarbeiten der Finanzminister reagiert
mit einer Haushaltssperre alle Ausgaben
für den klimafond erstmal
gestrichen die Bundesregierung
respektiert dieses Urteil es schafft
Klarheit zur
Schuldenbremse das Urteil hat allerdings
potenziell weitgehende Auswirkungen auf
die Staatspraxis und die
Haushaltspolitik von Bund und allen
Ländern viele Vorhaben der Ampel liegen
nun auf Eis ausgenommen sind nur bereits
zugesagte Mittel etwa für
Gebäudesanierung die Zukunft zahlloser
andere meist grüner Prestigeprojekte
zumindest ungewiss ich nenne ein paar
Beispiele die Übernahme der EEG Umlage
und damit die Senkung der Stromkosten
für alle Verbraucherin und Verbraucher
von normalen Bürgerinnen und Bürgern bis
zum über den deutschen Mittelstand bis
zur Industrie die Förderung von
Immobilität inklusive der
ladesäuleninfrastruktur die Union die
kzruh geklagt hatte sieht sich bestätigt
der Oppositionsführer sehr zufrieden die
Bundesregierung muss jetzt das erste Mal
in ihrer Amtszeit etwas tun was sie bis
jetzt sorgfältig vermieden hat sie muss
mit dem Geld auskommen das im
Bundeshaushalt vereinnahmt wird woher
diese Einnahmen jedoch kommen sollen
weiß bisher noch niemand so genau die
Beamten im Finanzministerium werden
jedenfalls viele Überstunden machen
müssen zur politischen Betrachtung gehen
wir nach Berlin ins Hauptstadtstudio zu
Diana zimmermann eine klare Ansage aus
karlsroh und ein riesiges Finanzloch für
die Ampel wie geht die Regierung jetzt
damit
um der Kanzler und der Finanzminister
gaben sich heute betont gelassen obwohl
die Härte des Urteils für sie schlimmer
ist als Sie erwartet haben der
Wirtschaftsminister sah doch sehr
angeschlagen aus aus dem Klima und
transformationsfond sollten viele grüne
Projekte finanziert werden er muss nun
völlig neu aufgestellt werden für die
Zukunft gibt es für die Ampel nur
folgende Optionen entweder weniger Geld
ausgeben mehr einnehmen also Steuern
erhöhen oder eben die Schuldenbremse
aussetzen dafür aber bräuchte die ampe
eine zwei Drittel Mehrheit in Bundestag
und Bundesrat also die Unterstützung der
Union und die hat heute noch mal sehr
deutlich Nein dazu gesagt Diana zuletzt
gab es enorme fliegkräfte und
Streitereien in der Bundesregierung was
bedeutet das Urteil jetzt für die
ampelzukunft ja also die dieses Urteil
ist wirklich eine Zerreißprobe für die
Ampel die tatsächlich schon sehr lange
heftig und bitter darüber streitet wofür
sie Geld ausgeben will dass einer der
Koalitionäre hinschmeißt ist dennoch
unwahrscheinlich denn wenn man sich die
Umfragewerte der Parteien anschaut so
sind Neuwahlen für keine der
ampelparteien besonders verlockend ihre
Chancen darauf die Gunst der Wähler in
den nächsten zwei Jahren wieder
zurückzugewinnen allerdings sind mit dem
heutigen Urteil auch noch mal drastisch
gesunken denn vieles was die Regierung
gestalten wollte ist nun einfach nicht
mehr möglich weil das Geld fehlt danke
für die Analyse nach Berlin Diana
Zimmermann schauen wir jetzt in den
Nahen Osten nach tagelangen kämpfen mit
der Hamas hat die israelische Armee
jetzt das alschifer Krankenhaus im
gazaastreifen gestürmt es handelt sich
um die größte Klinik in der Region sie
befindet sich in der Stadt Gaza die
israelische Armee die geht davon aus
dass die Hamas das Gebäude als
Kommandozentrale nutzt wie diese
Animation des israelischen geheim
zeigen soll und mehr dazu erfahren wir
jetzt von Stefan
Schlösser im Inneren des alschifer
Krankenhauses vor dem Eindringen der
israelischen Soldaten vergangene Nacht
die andauernden Kämpfe haben den Betrieb
fast unmöglich gemacht in der Dunkelheit
betreten dann die Truppen das Gebäude
Bilder davon gibt es noch nicht
telefonisch beschreibt ein Arzt diesen
Moment alle waren wirklich verängstigt
die Situation war wirklich schwierig sie
haben die Krankenhausverwaltung
angerufen und gesagt dass sie in ein
Gebäude nach dem anderen reingehen und
alles im Krankenhaus überprüfen werden
sie haben uns also vorher
informiert die Armee veröffentlichte
Aufnahmen die zeigen sollen wie Soldaten
dringend benötigte brutkäen bbnahrung
und weiteren medizinischen Bedarf ins
Krankenhaus bringen direkte Kämpfe mit
der hamass habe es im krankenus nicht
gegeben so ein
Armeesprecher hören auch ärzteeteams und
Arabisch Übersetzer die ein spezielles
Training absolviert haben um für diesen
sensiblen Einsatz vorbereitet zu sein
mit der Absicht dass den Zivilisten die
von der Hamas als Schutzschilde genutzt
werden kein Schaden zugefügt
wird während die Armee das Schifer
Krankenhaus weiter absucht gibt es auch
immer wieder Angriffe im Süden von Gaza
nach einem Schlag aus der Luft bleiben
am Boden nur Trümmer zurück wer sagt
dass es hier sicher ist seht was hier
passiert war ein Wohnhaus das zerstört
wurde unser Heim wurde auch zerstört und
diese Geschäfte alles ist
zerstört ein weiterer Tag der Zerstörung
bringt es ist der 40 dieses
Krieges und wir sprechen noch einmal mit
Michael beverunge in telaviv dazu
Israels Militär Michael ist ins größte
Krankenhaus in Gaza eingedrungen auf der
Suche nach der Hamas Kommandozentrale
wie ist der aktuelle
Stand also die letzte allerdings
bestätigte Meldung besagt dass die
israelischen Soldaten inzwischen wieder
abgezogen sind offenbar nachdem sie das
Krankenhaus gründlich durchkämmt haben
für die Armee war das ja ein schwieriger
Balanceakt einerseits die vermuteten
Kämpfer unter dem Krankenhaus bekämpfen
auf der anderen Seite die
die Zivilisten die Flüchtlinge die
Patienten die Ärzte über dem über der
Basis zu schützen nach dem
Kriegsvölkerrecht ein sehr schwieriges
Unterfangen und der Armee ist es zwar
offenbar gelungen aber es war eben nicht
ganz klar ob es gelingen würde äh im
Moment ist auch unklar was unterhalb des
Krankenhauses passiert ist ob es
tatsächlich eine Basis der Hamas dort
gegeben hat ob es gibt es spricht vieles
dafür wenn das so wäre wäre das übrigens
auch ein klares Kriegsverbrechen äh nach
dem internationalen Kriegsvölkerrecht
der Armee hat gesagt sie will sehr sehr
vorsichtig in dem Krankenhaus vorgehen
und ein Armeesprecher hat gesagt es
werde im Laufe des Tages noch mal
Beweise vorgelegt werden dass ich
tatsächlich das Hauptquartier der Hamas
unter dem schiferkrankenhaus befindet
auf meine Nachfrage kurz vor der Sendung
gab es noch keine Bestätigung nur dass
es tatsächlich so sein soll dass diese
Beweise noch vorgelegt werden vielen
dank Michael bwunge nach Tel Aviv und
alles zum Israel Hamas Krieg aber auch
zu allen anderen relevanten Themen
finden Sie jederzeit auf der z DF heute
ziemlich einfach aber auch unter
Aktuelles bei Whatsapp scannen Sie dafür
einfach den angezeigten QR-Code oder
abonnieren Sie uns direkt bei Whatsapp
selbst dann haben Sie alles Wichtige vom
Tag kurz und kompakt mit den Updates
jeweils morgens und
abends auf der italienischen
Mittelmeerinsel Lampedusa sind binnen
weniger Stunden wieder mehr als 1300
Bootsflüchtlinge angekommen sie stammen
laut Behörden vorwiegend aus Syrien
Ägypten Pakistan und Bangladesch seit
Anfang des Jahres erreichten mindestens
146 000 Migranten Italien über den
seeeweg wie Europa mit diesen Menschen
umgeht und ihre Zahl möglichst begrenzt
darüber streitet die EU ja weiterhin ein
Vorschlag wurde dabei zuletzt immer
häufiger gemacht man könne doch
außerhalb Europas über ihre Asylanträge
entscheiden so wie Großbritannien das
eigentlich geplant hatte illegale
Migranten wollte London ins
ostafrikanische Ruanda Ausfliegen das
aber hat der oberste britische
Gerichtshof heute für gesetzeswidrig
erklärt aus London dazu Hilke
Petersen stoppt die Bote das ist der
politische Slogan für den britischen
Plan Flüchtlinge nach Ruanda
abzuschieben jetzt stoppten die Richter
die Regierung die Beschwerde des
Innenministeriums wird
abgewiesen etwa 27000 kamen bisher in
diesem Jahr über den Ärmelkanal in boten
einen Asylantrag en sie nur in Ruanda
stellen würde der Plan der Regierung
aufgehen doch die Richter befürchten
dass von dort Menschen in ihre
Heimatländer zurückgeschickt werden und
ihn Misshandlung drohen könnte solche
Fälle berichtet das
unfüchtlingshilfswerk gut möglich dass
sich Großbritannien jetzt von
internationalen flüchtlingskonventionen
lossagt um doch noch abschieben zu
können Premierminister sunak bekräftigt
das nach der Niederlage vor
Gericht ich habe parl gesag wir ändern
und internationale Verpflichtungen neu
betrachten werden um Hindernisse zu
beseitigen ich werde keinem
ausländischen Gericht erlauben solche
abschiebeflüge zu
stoppen der Kampf um das Ruanda Modell
dürfte
weitergehen wir werden gegen alle
Bemühungen Vorgehen die europäische
Flüchtlingskonvention zu verlassen ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass es dazu
wirklich eine Befugnis gäbe sonak hat
Ruandas Präsidenten Kagame heute bereits
angerufen man wolle Festhalten an der
asülpartnerschaft mit einem
Drittland auch für Deutschland dürfte
das Urteil interessant sein seit die
Regierung prüfen will ob in Ländern
außerhalb Europas Asylverfahren denkbar
wären die britischen Richter sehen dafür
grundsätzlich die Möglichkeit es müsse
sich aber um einen erwiesenermaßen
sicheren stat
Handeln zurück nach Deutschland im
vergangenen April hatte ein sogenannter
Reichsbürger bei der geplanten
Durchsuchung seines Hauses minutenlang
auf Polizeibeamte geschossen und einen
von ihnen dabei schwer verletzt das
Oberlandesgericht Stuttgart verurteilte
den Mann jetzt wegen versuchten Mordes
in mehreren Fällen zu 14 Jahren und 6
Monaten Haft die Verteidigung hatte
Freispruch gefordert der 55-Jährige
hatte in seinem Haus in Boxberg in
BadenWürttemberg ein umfangreiches
Waffenarsenal
gehortet weniger als jeder fünfte Zug im
Fernverkehr und massive Einschränkungen
im Regionalverkehr so wird sich laut
Bahn der Streik der
lockführergewerkschaft GDL von heute 22
Uhr bis morgen 18 Uhr auswirken und was
da auf Bahnreisende alles zukommt
berichten jetzt Stefanie Hein und nels
Schneider der Streik ist recht
kurzfristig angesetzt die Kundinnen und
Kunden der Bahn müssen sich arrangieren
ich halte nichts davon und bin froh oder
hoffe dass ich von Berlin nach mannhim
kommen heute Abend ich habe total viel
Verständnis für die Anliegen aber man
ist natürlich trotzdem sel Sel ein
bisschen verhindert im Alltag also ich
denke mal ich werde auf jeden Fall
versuchen mit mehr Puffer zu planen ein
Unding nennt die Bahn den Streik und
warnt umfänglich wir rechnen damit dass
weniger als 20% der Intercity und ICE
Züge fahren im Regionalverkehr wird es
ebenfalls massive Einschränkungen geben
erfahrungsgemäß gibt's dabei regionale
Unterschiede wir rechnen auch damit dass
in einzelnen Regionen gar keine Züge
mehr fahren können wichtig für Fahrgäste
ein Notfahrplan ist online zu finden
Tickets für Mittwoch oder Donnerstag
sind auch später gültig bei zugausfall
wird der volle Fahrpreis erstattet
insgesamt rätt die Bahn Fahrten wenn
möglich zu verschieben sie will im
Notfahrplan längere Züge einsetzen kann
aber nicht garantieren dass jede und
jeder der fahren muss auch mitkommt die
Gewerkschaft der Lockführer rechtfertigt
den Streik die Arbeitgeberseite hatten
Angebot gemacht das war sehr
provozierend und sie hat klar und
deutlich gemacht sie wollen nicht über
die Wochenarbeitszeit verhand und den
Warnstreik der Verhandlung begleitet ist
nmer erstens nichts Neues und zweitens
auch nichts unbilliges die Bahn hat für
morgen geplante Gespräche mit der
lockführergewerkschaft abgesagt
verhandeln und gleichzeitig streken das
passe nicht wie es jetzt weitergeht noch
völlig
unklar bei uns ist es klar bei uns
geht's mit im Sport weiter und Christin
und es gibt die inzwischen dritte
Trainerin Entlassung in dieser noch
relativ jungen bundesligis aber schon
ein ganz besonderer Abschied die
Mechanismen des Profifußballs haben nun
doch auch die Alter erreicht nach 14
Pflichtspielen ohne Sieg und dem Absturz
auf den letzten Tabellenplatz der
Bundesliga trennen sich Union Berlin und
Trainer Urs Fischer nach innigen gut 5
Jahren die Liebe der Union Fans für Urs
Fischer mag noch so groß sein gegen eine
Niederlagenserie gigantischen Ausmaßes
kam sie einfach nicht mehr an mochte der
behauptungswille des beliebten
Schweizers nach der letzten Heimpleite
gegen Frankfurt durch die Fans auch noch
mal gestärkt worden
sein WN man eine solche Unterstützung
genießt logisch ist man ja auch bereit
dafür zu kämpfen als aber am Sonntag in
Leverkusen die neunte bundesligapleite
nacheinander folgte wurde die Trennung
unvermeidlich absolut einvernehmlich
versichert heute sein Präsident wir
hatten vereinbart dass er den Zeitpunkt
festlegt und ich danach entscheide und
somit ist es eine gemeinsame
Entscheidung geworden Fischer hatte
Union 2019 in die Bundesliga
geführt
der Vater des Erfolgs danach ging es
immer nur aufwärts bis hoch in die
Champions League nun aber der fast
unerklärlicher Absturz nach Fischer soll
nun U19 Trainer grote die Wende
schaffen erfolgreicher Einstand für die
Frauen von Eintracht Frankfurt in die
Champions League erstes Vorrundenspiel
gleich ein Sieg 2:1 beim schwedischen
Meister FC
rosengort Kapitänin Tanja P sorgt für
den ersten Glücksmoment in Frankfurt
Champions League Historie i 1:0 nach 24
Minuten ebnet der Eintracht den Weg zum
gelungenen Debüt in der
Königsklasse trotz eher
durchschnittlicher Leistung es ist ihr
achtes Pflichtspiel nacheinander ohne
Niederlage in dem Barbara Dunst in der
84 Minute das 2:0 gelingt nach
resultatskosmetik der Schwedinnen durch
Show genießen die hessinen im Stadion
Malmö idrotzplatz einen glanzarmen
Arbeitssieg Sieges Sieg Hauptsache
gewonnen oder gewon genau danke Christin
so zum Schluss noch eine Geschichte die
besonders die Fans der Royals begeistern
dürfte König Charles ist jetzt auch auf
kanadischen dollarm Münzen zu bewundern
Anlass für die Präsentation sein 75
Geburtstag 350 Künstler hatten
Designvorschläge beim britischen
Königshaus eingereicht und einer hat's
dann wohl gemacht so von kanadischen
Dollars zum möglichen euroewinn hier
sind nämlich die Lottozahlen und die
lauten 8 13 14 22 25 29 die Superzahl
lautet 1 weitere Gewinnzahlen und Infos
auf
lotto.zf.de und auf der ZDF Textseite
557 neuer Regen ist angesagt und auch
ein neuer Sturm mehr dazu gleich von
östen terli ich empfehle Ihnen noch
gerne das heute journal ab
21:45 mit Christian siers so viel von
uns für Sie noch einen entspannten
Abend
[Musik]
schön guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ein Sturm zieht
auf und wird uns morgen Abend erreichen
sehen es hier kommt von Frankreich rüber
und erwischt hauptsächlich die Südhälfte
Deutschlands und bereits in den
Vormittagsstunden beginnt es im
Südwesten zu regnen und das ganze Verlag
lagert sich allmählich nach Osten in der
kommenden Nacht regnet es im Osten
bereits und das ganze verlagert sich
nordostwärts und zieht langsam raus im
Südwesten da wird es allmählich trocken
bei tiefsten Temperaturen von 0° am
Alpenrand sonst bei 3 bis 7° durchweg
einstellige Temperaturen ja und morgen
im Nordosten Schauer und etwas Regen was
sich allmählich verabschiedet dazwischen
lockert es auf mal kommt die Sonne
hervor aber im Südwesten kommt hier auch
Regen auf im Tagesverlauf und verlagert
sich ostwärts und der Sturm der zieht
dann zum Abend auf bei 5 bis
12° und so sieht das dann mit dem Sturm
aus von Südwesten her kommt er auf und
verlagert sich ostwärts das ist die
Nacht von Donnerstag auf Freitag die
nächsten Tage am Freitag zieht der Sturm
raus bei 3 bis 9° Samstag relativ
trocken schönen Abend